mes chers collègues nous poursuivons les
travaux de notre mission d'information
sur le développement d'une filière de
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert en accueillant
ce soir Philippe Mauguin président
directeur général de l'INR AA donc
institut national de recherche pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement monsieur moguin a occupé
des fonctions de chercheurs des
fonctions cabinet ministérielles et des
fonctions exécutives en administration
déconcentrée en administration centrale
et en agence vous avez notamment été
directeur d'agriculture et des BIOS
énergies à l'ADEME conseiller du Premier
ministre pour l'agriculture la forêt et
l'alimentation est director cabinet du
ministre de l'Agriculture avant de
prendre la tête de l'Institut national
de la recherche agronomique devenue ni
après sa fusion avec l'IRST
a c'est-à-dire institut national de
recherche en sciences et technologie
pour l'environnement et l'agriculture ce
motard est accompagné par plusieurs
personnes que je tiens à saluer madame
Monique Alex los
directrice scientifique alimentation et
bio-économie monsieur Luc philodo
directeur d'instituts Carnot 3B car
qui accompagne les entreprises dans le
développement d'innovation dans les
domaines des BIOS énergies des
biomélectus et des matériaux biosés et
Bernard curec directeur de recherche à
l'Institut mixte de recherche
fractionnement des agro ressources et
environnement c'est-à-dire phare
participe également
en audition et à l'audition et en visio
Monsieur Nicolas Bernay directeur du
laboratoire de biotechnologie de
l'environnement de Narbonne et Madame
Isabelle Brossier chef de cabinet de
Monsieur Mauger alors cette réunion elle
est captée et diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat sur lequel elle
pourra ensuite être consultée en vidéo à
la demande monsieur le Président
Directeur Général mesdames et messieurs
notre mission d'information
comprend des membres issus des
différentes commissions du Sénat qui
représentent en même temps l'ensemble
des groupes politiques de notre
assemblée le développement des filières
de biocarburant de carburant synthétique
durable et d'hydrogène vert représente
un enjeu important pour permettre à la
France et à l'Union européenne
d'atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050 mais aussi pour
notre souveraineté et la compétitivité
de notre économie la France a développé
une politique ambitieuse en matière de
biocarburant qui a eu des effets
significatifs tant en termes de
production que d'incorporation de biodes
ou de bioéthanol dans les carburants ces
orientations se trouvent aujourd'hui
contestées ou interrogés par certains
certains organismes pour synthétiser
nous avons eu trois grands types de
questionnements ou d'interpellations
concernant les biocarburants tout
d'abord les analyses des acteurs
divergent parfois sur l'intérêt des
biocarburants de première génération en
tenant compte à la fois de l'enjeu de
résilience du monde agricole de la
concurrence des usages agricoles et du
bilan environnemental global de ces
biocarbures nous serons évidemment
attentifs à votre analyse ensuite
l'enjeu que représente la biomasse en
dehors de la première génération
a donné lieu à des prises de position
très contrastées certains acteurs
considèrent que la ressource est
drastiquement limitée et qu'elle soulève
des problèmes difficiles de collecte
efficace tandis que d'autres ont une
vision c'est pas si on dit beaucoup plus
positif sur le sujet c'est évidemment un
point majeur car de cette analyse peut
découler à la fois les options de
répartition des carburants entre
filières mais aussi certaines analyses
sur une forme contrainte de sobriété
nous avons également eu des approches
très contrastées concernant les
biocarburants de 2e ou troisième
génération et sur la capacité à passer à
un mode de production industrielle à
l'horizon de temps raisonnable lors de
notre visite au centre du CEA à
cadaraesh vendredi dernier nous avons
évoqué avec les
évoquer les recherches en cours sur les
micro-algues mais il ne s'agit pas d'une
solution à déploiement rapide si nous
avons bien suivi les choses nous sommes
heureux d'entendre l'analyse de
l'irre qui est une expertise spécifique
sur ces sujets notre rapporteur monsieur
capo canelas qui est à l'origine
d'ailleurs notre mission vous a adressé
un questionnaire qui peut servir de
guide mais vous pouvez introduire votre
propos comme vous l'entendez je passerai
ensuite la parole à notre rapporteur
puis à l'ensemble de mes collègues afin
qu'il puisse vous relancer et vous poser
un certain nombre de questions vous
pourrez nous transmettre
ultérieurement des réponses écrites aux
questions qui vous ont été adressées
monsieur manga je vous cède la parole
pour 15 à 20 minutes merci
s'il vous plaît mettez bien votre micro
je le dis à tout le monde voilà parce
que
là comme ça c'est mieux
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs sénatrices merci déjà de nous
recevoir avec ma délégation inray dans
cette belle salle pour un sujet qui nous
tient à cœur comme vous qui est la
question de des bio énergies de la
bio-économie qui doit s'intégrer et je
vais peut-être commencer par là mon
introduction évidemment dans une
stratégie globale de développement de
l'agriculture et de la forêt alors inray
quelques mots rapides vous l'avez dit et
l'Institut national de la recherche pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement
issus de la fusion de l'INRA et de
l'irester et à l'occasion de cette
fusion qui a eu lieu en 2020 on a
redéfini en lien évidemment avec les
acteurs socio-économiques les
partenaires scientifiques les pouvoirs
publics une stratégie pour l'institut
une stratégie de recherche à l'horizon
2030 on a au sein de cette stratégie
cinq grandes priorités dont une qui est
dédiée à la bio économie une première
axe stratégique d'inrae ça vous
surprendra pas c'est de bien comprendre
les changements climatiques les
changements globaux qui vont impacter
notre planète et notre pays dans les
prochaines décennies pour adapter
l'agriculture la forêt les systèmes
alimentaires à ces dérèglements
climatiques
atténuer aussi quand c'est possible
deuxième axe c'est l'accélération de la
transition agroécologique de notre
système agricole donc comment rester
compétitif en s'adaptant assez nouveau à
ce nouveau concept ce nouveau contexte
troisième axe est dédié à la bio
économie qui est le sujet dont on va
parler ce soir et donc on veut
promouvoir une vision de la bio-économie
qui soit à la fois
circulaire et sobre et je vais y revenir
ensuite parce que on voit bien qu'il y a
beaucoup d'attentes sur la biomasse et
que répondre aux défis de l'alimentation
de la planète en 2050 avec une
population mondiale diale qui augmente
et en même temps répondre au défi de la
bioénergie c'est quelque chose de pas
évident donc on travaille sur cet axe de
recherche on pourrait y revenir avec mes
collègues pour
identifier des voies de valorisation de
la biomasse qui soit les plus efficaces
possible dans une logique d'économie
circulaire
et dans les Territoires puisque on peut
avoir une stratégie nationale une
stratégie internationale mais on sait
qu'une partie de la réponse va se
trouver dans les territoires et que
c'est au niveau des territoires qu'on
réussira à faire des formes de
covalorisation entre les débouchés
alimentaires et les débouchés
énergétiques puis après on a un
quatrième axe autour de la santé globale
qui est un autre sujet qui est
évidemment intéresse le Sénat comment on
prévient les futurs pandémies et comment
on est sûr le maximum la santé de nos
concitoyens par une alimentation de
qualité et puis un cinquième axe
stratégique qui est lié à la
mobilisation du digital du numérique
dans l'ensemble de nos activités de
recherche voilà c'est les cinq axes
stratégiques c'était juste en guise
d'introduction pour vous dire que la bio
économie est au cœur de la stratégie
lyrique qui est le premier organisme de
recherche en Europe dans son secteur et
dans les deux ou trois premiers au
niveau mondial avec une montée en
puissance que je cite au passage des
acteurs chinois qui sont en train train
de rattraper dépasser tout le monde les
Américains et les Européens
depuis avant qu'il linerait existe
l'Inra a travaillé et lycéenne c'est
Maghreb aussi d'ailleurs aux côtés des
filières agricoles parfois en
anticipation même pour accompagner le
développement des vieux carburants à
l'époque les biocarburants de première
génération à cette époque moi j'étais à
l'Agence de l'environnement et de
l'énergie à l'ADEME j'étais directeur
vous l'avez dit l'agriculture des et des
bioénergies et c'est l'occasion de
saluer le travail qu'on avait pu
conduire avec Pierre Cuypers et d'autres
responsables professionnels pour
développer ses premières générations de
biocarburant
donc aujourd'hui on est passé en tant
que recherche plutôt à ce qu'on appelle
la seconde génération c'est on considère
que la première génération est plutôt
mature la production de dethanol
issue de différents substrats ou des
stères de colza ou des stères d'huile
issues de différents substrats et plutôt
opérationnels et d'ailleurs on a un
développement industriel qu'on peut
saluer en France et en Europe et donc la
recherche qu'on mène aujourd'hui à
Israël va être plutôt sur des secondes
générations on va donc dans notre
logique de bio-économie circulaire
essayez de valoriser des coûts produits
des sous-produits de la biomasse
l'igmosellulosique par exemple la paille
mais pas uniquement ça peut être aussi
la Ligue nos cellulose ou de la biomasse
forestière avec des sous-produits de
transformation du bois et donc ça c'est
pas si simple que ça à faire pour
extraire les sucres qu'il y a dans ces
biomasse pour ensuite pouvoir les faire
monter et produire par exemple de
l'éthanol c'est plus compliqué que quand
on part de betterave ou quand on part de
de blé donc on a des recherches là
dessus si vous le souhaitez on pourrait
y revenir avec les collègues qui nous
accompagnent qui sont plus spécialisés
sur ces sujets Monique axelo ça tout
moment pourra aussi intervenir parce
qu'elle a la vision globale dans son
portefeuille de directrice scientifique
alimentation et bio économique de cette
stratégie on va travailler aussi sur le
biogaz qui est un sujet qui je crois
rentre dans le mandat de votre
commission qui est évidemment en plein
essor moins développé si on regarde les
terawatters ou les équivalents d'un
équivalent pétrole que les filières
biocarburantes première génération mais
on voit qu'il y a un essor et on
travaille avec Nicolas Bernay qui est à
distance le directeur du laboratoire des
biotechnologies de l'environnement à
Narbonne on a des premiers centres de
recherche au niveau international sur la
méthanisation biogaz donc c'est un autre
sujet de de recherche qui est important
pour nous
enfin on a donc ces recherches
technologiques scientifiques
technologiques
fractionnement de la matière première
fermentation méthanisation gaz et
efficace mais on a aussi des recherches
plus globales de type économique ou
socio-économique pour voir justement et
c'est probablement au cœur de vos
discussions
quelle prospective on peut faire sur le
développement de ces filières comment on
va pouvoir concilier tous ces
développements et c'est pas un sujet si
simple comme je le disais en
introduction on doit se préparer à une
planète à 9 à 10 milliards d'habitants
donc avec une des besoins alimentaires
qui seraient en augmentation de 30% si
on prend un traîne d'un peu rapide avec
des surfaces agricoles au niveau mondial
qui vont pas pouvoir beaucoup progresser
surtout si on veut arrêter la
déforestation qui accélère le
dérèglement climatique on a quelques
marges de manœuvre mais pas nombreuses
les terres agricoles sont plutôt vous le
grignoter par l'urbanisation le
développement des mégalopoles qui
accueille les populations nouvelles les
progrès de la désertification et on doit
produire dans un contexte de dérèglement
climatique on a déjà en France et en
Europe plus constater depuis une dizaine
d'années la stagnation des rendements
agricoles là où les décennies
précédentes on avait une augmentation
régulière qui était liée au progrès
génétique à agronomique ce progrès
génétique qui continue d'être de sortir
de nos laboratoires il est contrecarré
par le dérèglement climatique donc on a
une stagnation des rendements ce qui
veut dire que il faut qu'on produise de
façon efficace au niveau mondial pour
nourrir cette population en croissance
avec des surfaces qui sont sous tension
des questionnements dans le cadre de la
décarbonation sur les intrants qu'on
pourra utiliser demain donc moins
d'engrais
moins d'engrais minéraux moins de
produits phytosanitaires à la fois pour
une logique de protection de
l'environnement de santé la population
mais aussi d'économie de carbone
fossiles donc tout ça c'est une équation
qui est pas simple alors pas là pour ce
soir dresser un tableau pessimiste les
chercheurs ils sont motivés à inray au
sein d'une ré mais pas uniquement dans
la communauté mondiale il y a des
scénarios qui permettent de boucler les
cycles c'est des scénarios qui vont
combiner une lutte contre le gaspillage
alimentaire dans les pays du Nord une
lutte contre les pertes de produits
après récolte dans les pays du Sud qui
manque d'infrastructure de stockage qui
vont prendre en compte une évolution des
régimes alimentaires on peut pas nourrir
9 à 10 milliards d'habitants en 2050 qui
est le même régime alimentaire que les
Nord-Américains aujourd'hui ou même que
les Européens du Nord et donc il faudra
qu'on rééquilibre à l'échelle mondiale
les régimes alimentaires avec un
équilibre entre les protéines animales
et les protéines végétales on aura
évidemment toujours besoin d'élevage
mais avec un équilibre à trouver si on
veut réussir à nourrir la population
mondiale donc ça c'est un axe le
gaspillage à lutte contre les
gaspillages j'en ai un autre et puis la
recherche Agron développement mondial
qui continue son travail à la fois sur
la génétique l'agronomie les
biotechnologies les sources alternatives
de protection des récoltes et quand on
dit tout ça il faut pas qu'on oublie
l'enjeu économique et l'enjeu des bio
énergies parce que cette première
équation elle est compliquée mais on
sait qu'on a besoin et on a des attentes
fortes pour produire de la biomasse pour
substituer le carbone fossile qu'on doit
décarboner et
du coup c'est là qu'on voit apparaître
ces tensions est-ce qu'on va y arriver
comment faire est-ce qu'on a les
ressources suffisantes et ça explique
probablement que vous ayez selon les
scénarios que prennent les études de
prospective qui vont être fait soit par
WWF soit par l'ADEME soit dans le cadre
de la SNBC soit par d'autres des
hypothèses qui vont vous paraître
extrêmement variables quand on se
projette à l'horizon en 2050 on n'a pas
réalisé côté inrae une prospective de
plus pour mettre tout le monde on
pourrait y contribuer c'est évidemment
assez compliqué mais on peut évidemment
donner avoir une des réactions d'experts
sur sur ces différentes stratégies ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut vraiment
jouer la carte
de biorinerie à l'échelle des
territoires qui jouent cette logique de
l'économie circulaire c'est-à-dire que
quand on rentre du blé quand on rentre
de la betterave quand on va rentrer des
nouvelles cultures qui peuvent être du
miscanthus du sorgho des sous-produits
de bois dans une Bior raffinerie il
faudra qu'elle puisse qu'on puisse
optimiser cette matière première pour ne
rien perdre et combiner une valorisation
sur des produits alimentaires on a
tendance à dire dans une logique que
certains appellent la logique 4F en
anglais excusez-moi food d'abord
l'alimentation humaine fide ensuite
l'alimentation animale fiber les fibres
les biomatériaux dont on aura besoin et
ensuite
fuel le quatrième F dans cette logique
là pour valoriser au mieux les produits
de la photosynthèse parce que
l'agriculture a réussi à produire à
partir de la photosynthèse c'est des
macromolécules complexes qui ont une
haute valeur ajoutée et donc il faut les
préserver au maximum d'abord pour
l'alimentation humaine évidemment
et je participe au projet de loi à la
préparation du projet de loi d'avenir
agricole à la demande du ministre Marc
féno avec d'autres et donc dans les
débats sur l'avenir de l'agriculture il
y a une forme de consensus entre le
monde agricole et les autres acteurs
pour dire la vocation de l'agriculture
française à l'horizon 2040 doit rester
d'abord nourricière et ensuite
elle doit évidemment contribuer aux
autres enjeux du bien commun dont
l'énergie les énergies renouvelables
mais il faut le prendre dans cet ordre
pour ça que nos recherches elles sont
aussi orientées sur ces logiques
d'économie circulaire de boucles de
valorisation et quand on a récupéré par
exemple des drêches et ben on va il faut
les valoriser au maximum quand on a
la possibilité d'avoir des pailles qui
sont pas utilisées pour le retour au sol
il faut les valoriser au maximum si on a
des cultures donc vous avez dû parler à
vos questions énergétique qui ont un
intérêt quand on les rentre dans les
rotations agricoles parce qu'elles vont
permettre de couvrir les soldes pas
laisser les sols nus de stocker du
carbone atmosphérique dans les sols
quand on va récolter cessives on va
laisser une partie probablement de la
cive ou des éléments déracinaires au sol
pour la matière organique et on va en
exporter une partie et cette partie là
elle va pas aller pour l'alimentation
humaine a priori
on a un deuxième et ça c'est un vrai bon
débat politique aussi vers quoi on
l’oriente est-ce qu'on la met dans les
méthaniseurs pour contribuer à faire du
gaz vert et à atteindre nos objectifs de
la SNBC en hydrogène ou est-ce qu'on la
met dans l'aditivation on fait une
fermentation pour produire de
l'aditivation au carburant des
automobilistes et où est-ce qu'on
prépare les carburants pour les
transports aériens dont on sait que ça
va être probablement le mode de
transport le plus compliqué à substituer
en énergie renouvelable puisque le
débouché électrique qui est en train de
progresser sur les véhicules
particulier a quand même et quand même
plus loin de la cible pour le transport
aérien donc on a des chercheurs et
nous-mêmes on essaye de réfléchir à ces
schémas là comment valoriser au mieux la
biomasse les produits de la
photosynthèse et après alors on va pas
se mettre à la place du politique dans
tous les cas on peut éclairer qu'est-ce
qui paraîtrait le plus logique et ce
qu'on réserve une partie de cette
biomasse pour produire du biogaz parce
qu'on aura besoin de gaz avant peut-être
qu'un jour on est de l'hydrogène qui
soit performant et qui soit fait par
l'électrolyse dans des conditions
performantes c'est pas avant 2040 ou
2050 on a devant nous et il y a c'est ça
qui est compliqué aussi faut qu'on
intègre le temps on sait qu'on a avec la
méthanisation une capacité à produire
dans des conditions efficaces de du CH4
du méthane qui peut aller dans le réseau
de gaz et fournir du gaz pour nos
concitoyens dans des conditions assez
performantes un jour arrivera de
l'hydrogène dans des conditions
sécurisées plus performantes qui pourra
peut-être remplacer le méthane pour le
moment on travaille sur l'ensemble de
ces voix et donc la question des
biocarburants aériens reste un sujet qui
est un sujet je crois d'un point de vue
international qui est considéré comme le
plus compliqué et donc peut-être que
dans le futur c'est vers les
biocarburants aériens qu'on réorientera
une partie de la biomasse
dédiée à la production de biocarburant
pour les transports même si il y a pas
de regret à avoir sur la première
génération la façon dont la filière
s'est développée en Esther de colza et
en éthanol ou en etpe a été une
finalement une approche assez
raisonnable et assez pragmatique
démarrer sur un segment où il y avait
des propriétés d'attitivation d'indice
d'octables pour le TPE d'un côté et de
lubrification avec les serres de colza
dans des gazon à bastonner en souffre
qui apportait un intérêt technique
dans l'aditivation qui apporte un
débouché au monde agricole à un moment
où on était en difficulté et il y avait
besoin de diversifier donc on a cette
première génération qui a sa logique
est-ce qu'on va la développer jusqu'à un
niveau très élevé la directive
européenne je crois parle d'un objectif
de 13 % de des carburants renouvelables
14 dont 7 pour première génération et 7
ou un peu moins pour la seconde
génération
3,5% pour la oui voilà je me tourne
aussi vers Luc philodo pour qu'il me
complètent donc les objectifs de la
directive européenne sont de 14% dont 7%
de biocarburant de première génération
et un objectif de 3,5% pour la seconde
génération
voilà donc c'est un petit peu global
comme premier approche mais pour camper
le paysage vous dire à la fois pourquoi
c'est un sujet important pour nous
dans l'émission de l'Institut et comment
le conçoit comment dans le temps on a
évolué d'un travail qui était vraiment
très très orienté sur la première
génération à un travail seconde
génération et on prépare aussi
l'approche plus globale des biographies
on pourrait peut-être dire un mot si
c'est pas trop long moi j'ai pas regardé
le timing monsieur le Président est-ce
que je suis dans mes 15 minutes où je
les ai dépassé
parce que
c'est un peu au-dessus les 15 minutes
peut-être que à ce moment là je peux
m'arrêter là
15 à 20 parce que l'autre ce qui aurait
pu être intéressant c'est que Monique
vous dise un mot de puisque j'ai parlé
de façon générale des approches dans les
territoires et des approches de centrale
comment on peut concevoir des
biocentrales ou des biographies du futur
peut-être que Monique dis un mot de
l'expérience qu'on a conduit avec le
projet Futurol merci
oui donc dans les dans les années donc
2008 on a démarré le projet Futurol qui
est donc l'utilisation
concevoir un démonstrateur pour
l'utilisation et la fabrication de
carburant ce qu'on appelle de 2e
génération à partir donc de la ligne
cellulose donc les pailles et du
miscanthus et des taillis à courtes à
court rotation c'est un projet qui avait
été mené avec plusieurs acteurs
industriels
et des mois je pense qu'il y avait il y
avait le safre il y avait total il y a
un total
des terrese
qu'on a amené à son à son terme en huit
ans à peu près et puis on l'a on l'a
monté avec l'IFPEN et donc c'est une
maintenant une licence qui
c'est Axens qui a cette licence à charge
et on commence et il commence à vendre
des
démonstrateurs dans différents pays
européens mais plutôt pays de l'Est
puisqu'ils ont la biomasse beaucoup de
biomasse et je pense qu'il y a peut-être
aussi une tentative en Inde je sais pas
je sais plus c'est là elle a réussi ou
pas donc voilà donc on avait fait la
preuve de concept avec ce démonstrateur
de transformer en tout cas tout ce qui
est lié aussi usique de type pie en
éthanol c'était la filière éthanol
par des voix couplées de prétraitement
de la biomasse suivi de l'hydrolyse
enzymatique
ce qui reste un verrou le prétraitement
de la biomasse reste un verrou pour la
l'utilisation optimale de tout ce qui
est carburant de 2e génération et on
continue à travailler là-dessus
c'est pas si au niveau international je
me tourne vers des collègues on peut
dire comment on se situe par rapport à
nos homologues quels sont les autres
pays qui sont les plus avancés en
recherche sur ces biocarbures de seconde
génération avec l'Américain avait
travaillé au niveau du National Rogneux
pour l'énergie laboratoriz sur le sujet
de la fragmentation il n'y a pas à ma
connaissance enfin je sais je me tourne
vers vous est-ce qu'il y a vraiment
peut-être du coluc des exemples concrets
de centrales qui fournissent des
biocarburants de seconde génération en
mode industriel
alors évidemment faudrait tout
revérifier derrière mais
les Etats-Unis donc ça c'est évidemment
ça a été évoqué mais au niveau du Brésil
c'était la même chose c'est la
valorisation des coproduits des bagages
et pour transformer justement cette
matière là donc en éthanol deuxième
génération
dans mon souvenir que c'est déjà
relativement ancien en fait je crois
qu'il y a eu des pilotes et des volumes
assez conséquents qui ont été produits
par contre je n'ai pas moi en tout cas
en tête maintenant des structures qui
tournent d'un point de vue industriel
donc en fait le savoir-faire est là mais
pour une raison probablement économique
n'a pas continué même aux États-Unis ils
ont beaucoup de problèmes je crois pour
arriver voilà en plus c'est pareil donc
ça a marché mais pour l'instant ça ne
marche plus enfin c'est plus
opérationnel on va dire mais la
technologie des murs on sait comment
faire maintenant je pense que c'est
effectivement le problème économique
derrière qui est c'est probablement une
logique économique c'est-à-dire que dans
ces pays les grands pays producteurs de
biocarburant que vous connaissez les les
États-Unis avec la filière et le Brésil
avec la filière de dethanol ex canne à
sucre c'est des productions massives
avec des soutiens publics qui sont
importants des filières matures au
niveau industriel et donc c'est très
difficile pour les carburants de
nouvelle génération de trouver un
avantage économique dans ce contexte
mais ils sont prêts pour un contexte où
le prix de l'énergie augmenterait ce qui
peut quand même on l'a vu à certains
moments quand il y a des crises il y a
des tensions qui peut arriver dans les
prochaines années on a des technologies
matures qui permettent d'ouvrir le le
sourcing l'approvisionnement de ces
unités avec des nouvelles technologies
pour de la bagasse de canne à sucre ou
pour des sous-produits des gnocellulosi
qui sont plus difficiles à travailler
donc il y a des coûts de transformation
qui sont plus élevés que que sur la
première génération mais en tous les cas
les technologies sont matures c'est
directement lié au prix du pétrole on
l'a très bien vu
Futurol et né d'une période où il a une
pétrole à remonter le prix du pétrole
remonté et tous les industriels ont
arrêté quand le prix du prétoral est
redevenu relativement bas et là on
revoit l'intérêt pour tout ce qui est
biomasse directement en lien avec la
avec la crise actuelle
pourquoi cet engouement qui qui revient
mais la technologie elle est elle est
mature en sûrement améliorée
malheureusement on a des engagements je
voudrais dire de me poser la question au
président que
sur les objectifs de 14% dont 7%
aujourd'hui pour vous c'est un taquet
parce que enfin c'est ce que je
comprends dans ce que vous exprimez
pour ma part j'ai aussi entendu dire et
au travers des filières que la capacité
on pouvait aller jusqu'à près de 9%. la
crise énergétique nous montre combien
aujourd'hui il est urgent de trouver une
solution d'approvisionnement et on
connaît le fonctionnement de cette
filière sachant que la deuxième
génération on sait aujourd'hui que si
techniquement on approche à des
solutions et économiquement elles ne
sont pas là
alors est-ce qu'il faut se priver et
comment vous voyez cette évolution
est-ce que vous pensez évoluer et faire
changer ce curseur que vous indiquez de
7% et puis après je voudrais vous
demander ce que vous pensez de la
surtransposition de la règle des
réglementations aujourd'hui qui pénalise
notre développement
notre développement énergétique et
développement tout court je dirais
agroalimentaire aussi
sur la première question c'est pas les
7% c'est pas une recommandation inrae
c'est l'état de la directive
communautaire c'est la réglementation
européenne donc on s'est pris voilà on a
pris cette référence dans une logique de
simulation de développement de biomasse
donc aujourd'hui
c'est des chiffres que vous devez
connaître auquel cas je vous prie de mon
excuser mais c'est pour donner un ordre
de grandeur la la consommation primaire
d'énergie renouvelable
en France et de 353
terawater en 2020 on a la première
source de d'énergie renouvelable c'est
le bois énergie on le sait dans notre
pays ça représente 102 terawatt-heure et
on a ensuite 33 terawatters qui viennent
des filières biocarburants
liquide donc les 33 terawatters c'est
2,9 millions de tonnes équivalent
pétrole dont le plus gros vient du
biodiel 2,4 millions de têtes et
0,6,0,6 millions de têtes du bioéthanol
donc pour revenir sur les pour avoir des
éléments de comparaison multipilière
102 terawattheure de bois énergie 33
terawatths de biocarburant et le petit
nouveau le biogaz qui se développe et
qui est à 13 terawater en 2020 en
progression de plus 16% par rapport à
2019 donc de l'univers agricole et
forestiers on peut déduire qu'on a
sans 102 et 33 135 TW et les 13 de
biogaz on est à pas loin de 150
térawattheure qui vient de la BI omasse
sur une production d'énergie
renouvelable je le disais une
consommation d'énergie renouvelable de
353 térats une petite moitié des
énergies renouvelables dans notre pays
sont déjà fournis par la forêt et
l'agriculture derrière la question que
pose
le sénateur Pierre Kuiper s'il y a
jusqu'où peut-on aller et donc face à ce
qu'on montrait différence scénarios
c'est qu'on pouvait augmenter on pouvait
consommer de la biomasse
d'origine agricole
sans trop de risques de concurrencer la
le débouché alimentaire aux alentours de
130 à 150 térawattheure par an
[Musique]
et de la méthanisation et donc si on
pousse le curseur loin sur le biogaz on
va avoir un petit peu moins de saü
disponible pour aller enchanté les 9%.
donc il y a des arbitrages à faire qui
sont des arbitrages je dirais politique
économique socio-économique
c'est pas les mêmes matières premières
mais ça peut être une partie de la
surface peut être utilisée donc c'est
probable il est certainement possible de
passer de cette à neuf pour cent
non mais c'est certainement possible je
veux pas te dire que on peut faire 7 ou
8% aujourd'hui qu'on pourrait pas faire
9 après il y a un sujet qui serait qui
est compliqué dans l'organisation des
filières on l'a vécu avec
malheureusement la guerre et on le vit
encore avec la guerre en Ukraine c'est
quand un moment il y a des tensions
fortes sur les débouchés alimentaires et
il faudrait qu'on ait mais c'est vrai
pour l'Europe comme c'est vrai pour les
États-Unis ou le Brésil il faudrait
qu'on ait une forme de réversibilité
c'est à dire si on si on va plus loin
dans les filières
biocarburantes première génération il
faudrait qu'on soit en capacité de dire
les pouvoirs publics et les
professionnels que en cas de tension on
va baisser la production de biocarburant
pour augmenter la production de produits
alimentaires et la question elle a
vraiment failli se poser quand tout
était bloqué la sortie des céréales on
avait déjà le tournesol qui plongeait
puisque l'Ukraine était bloqué il y a on
a vu le moment dans l'initiative farm
qui avait prise de président de la
République
on aurait pu solliciter à la fois
l'Union européenne mais aussi les
États-Unis et le Brésil pour baisser les
volumes de production de biocarburant
pour remettre plus en alimentation donc
moi je serai à titre personnel
ouvert à l'idée je peux engager une raie
sur un sujet comme ça techniquement oui
c'est possible mais si on augmente la
production de biocarburant de première
génération pour un intérêt
d'attitivation d'oxygénation il faudrait
qu'on soit en capacité en maturité
l'ensemble des acteurs pour reconnaître
que en cas de crise internationale de
tension sur les approvisionnements on
pourrait en produire moins et accepter
d'en produire moins pour pouvoir
produire plus d'alimentation je pense
que ça permettrait en tous les cas
d'avoir des débats plus sereins parce
que souvent les acteurs s'accusent de ça
en disant mais vous allez développer les
biocarburants on va faire des usines en
plus et si demain il y a à nouveau des
tensions parce qu'il y a des mauvaises
récoltes où la guerre en Ukraine se
redire on n'arrive plus à sortir les
productions comment on va faire donc il
faudrait qu'on soit en capacité c'est
pas simple parce qu'évidemment quand
vous gérez une raffinerie et vous avez
des carburants qui renouvelables qui
arrivent chaque année c'est difficile de
s'en abstrait donc ça c'est peut-être
une suggestion que je livre à votre
assemblée
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
président merci de ce que vous avez
apporté au débat notamment réponse à
l'excellente question de de mon collègue
Pierre Cuypers je vais revenir sur
différents points que vous avez abordés
pour m'assurer qu'on peut cranter un peu
des éléments du débat comme on dit
parfois vous venez de dire 150
erreurs
issus de la biomasse agricole et autant
de la biomasse forestière ça fait partie
des objectifs qu'on peut se fixer alors
pour la carte du débat ça voudrait dire
combien de progression par rapport à
aujourd'hui
premier élément ensuite j'entends le
débat que vous posez ou plutôt la
logique en disant que on viendra
l'hydrogène
véritablement via l'électrolyse si j'ai
bien saisi vous me le préciserez plutôt
en 2040 2050 avec une production plutôt
forte et puis en même temps vous avez
dit tout à l'heure je reprends votre
formule je crois pas vous trahir c'est
même si
via la filière agricole au sens au sens
large dans votre dans votre champ de
recherche aujourd'hui
je vais commencer peut-être par les
premières questions et je laisserai
Monique éventuellement répondre à la
fois sur donc je vais répondre sur la
l'évolution
que rend possible c'est l'évocation de
ces gisements après un retour sur les
vieux carburants première génération
après est-ce qu'on appelle être mature
techniquement sur les secondes
générations à partir de l'expérience
futurale et puis après les comment tu
vois et peut-être aussi
Luke ou Bernard les fonds de recherche y
compris dans ce qu'on fait avec le
Carnot quels sont les les voilà les
choses un petit peu folles auxquelles
peuvent rêver les chercheurs aujourd'hui
sur
exactement non non mais ça s'appelle
encore une fois un mauvais français le
la recherche blue sky quand on ou les
les moonshots quoi les voilà qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui serait équivalent
aller sur la Lune aujourd'hui et
l'hydrogène du coup on te donnera la
parole Nicolas si tu le veux bien pour
dire quels sont les points de les
perspectives de développement
d'hydrogène donc quand je reviens sur la
question des potentiels de biomasse
mobilisables les chiffres que je cite il
faut quand même toujours donner ces
sources mais on voulait redonnera
ensuite comme sur le Président vous y
avez invité en répondant sur une version
écrite à votre questionnaire
on a plusieurs scénarios il y a un
scénario qui est
le moins optimiste c'est celui WWF qui
est quand même intéressant qui donne une
référence il y en a qui sont beaucoup
plus optimistes c'était le cas d'un
scénario de l'ADEME et puis un scénario
médian qui est celui de France stratégie
je crois donc je vais pas tous les citer
mais pour la biomasse agricole ils sont
pas si éloignés WWF disait 120 à 130
térawh par an et France stratégie 150
kawattheure par an donc si je ne me
trompe pas parce qu'évidemment il y
avait des forêts de chiffres le chiffre
que je vous donnais tout à l'heure pour
la biomasse purement agricole
en ne revenant pas sur le bois énergie
aujourd'hui c'était entre une trentaine
de terrawattheure ils ont 33 Tera water
en consommation peut-être 27 en
production qui vont vers les
biocarburants de première génération
auquel on peut rajouter parce qu'on va
rentrer ça dans la biomasse agricole les
13 terawatters qui vont dans la filière
biogaz puisque ça va être des déjections
animales mais ça va être aussi des
produits fibreux qui vont être mis en
mélange qui sont ou dessives qui sont
d'origine agricole donc 27 et 13 40 tt
c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui sous le
contrôle de mes collègues 40
terawattheure d'origine agricole et une
perspective de monter à 140 150 donc une
forme de triplement
de biomasse mobilisable là aussi puisque
j'avais fait moi j'avais piloté une
prospective pour la Commission de
régulation de l'électricité de l'énergie
mais Monique axelo c'est à poursuivi ce
travail et donc n'hésite pas à me
compléter ou à me corriger sur ce point
dans les derniers travaux et donc là où
c'est pas stabilisé c'est que la creux a
fait ses nous avaient demandé de faire
des projections mais orientées gaz
renouvelable que ce soit du méthane ou
de l'hydrogène renouvelable et donc on
avait pris des scénarios à partir de
cette biomasse mobilisable mais on n'a
pas regardé en faisant ça des hypothèses
de développement volontariste de
biocarburant liquide pour les transports
quand Pierre Cuyper sous votre
commission me poser la question jusqu'où
peut-on aller on voit qu'il y a ces
équilibres à trouver il me semble
raisonnable de dire que il faut pas
dépasser ce potentiel de biomasse de 140
à 150 térawh à l'horizon 2042 2050 ça
nous fait une progression par rapport à
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui en
biocarburant liquide et biogaz X3 déjà
falloir le faire
de façon ordonnée sur le territoire sans
déstabiliser les filières alimentaires
en valorisant les coproduits en tenant
compte et on sait qu'il y a des débats
dans certaines régions y compris dans le
monde agricole du devenir dessives
est-ce qu'on met des couverts entre les
cultures principales de rente est-ce que
c'est pour pour faire de
des fourrages faire moins d'importation
de fourrage de l'étranger pour nos
troupeaux est-ce que c'est pour en
laisser faire du retour au sol la
matière organique ou est-ce que c'est
pour l'exporter donc la réponse elle est
probablement dans une forme d'équilibre
c'est à dire qu'on a besoin de laisser
que ce soit des résidus de paille ou que
ce soit des couverts en partie sur le
sol pour garder de la matière organique
séquestrer du carbone assurer la
fertilité à long terme faut pas tout
exporter il faut en laisser mais il y a
une partie qui peut être mobilisée pour
faire soit de l'alimentation animale en
substitution à l'al imentation importée
qui peut être aussi une source de
déforestation on pense notamment à
l'Amérique latine donc il y a un enjeu
d'alimentation animale mais il y a un
potentiel pour faire de la bioénergie et
cette bioénergie elle est pour le moment
plutôt orientée méthanisation biogaz
donc dans la surface agricole utile ce
que disait pierre Cuyper c'est qu'on
pouvait probablement passer de 7 à 9%
ces techniquesment possible je disais de
façon prudentielle puisque j'ai pas
regardé les chiffres sur ce scénario là
que ça serait bien d'avoir quand même si
on développait les biocarbures en Europe
de première génération des clauses de
revoyure en cas de tension alimentaire
et que je pense que ça serait bien de le
rentrer dans les débats dans les mandats
d'incorporation de biocarburant mais ça
c'était un point de vue personnel je
pense que ça sera de toute façon si on
allait si les pouvoirs publics
rediscutaient de la directive européenne
au Parlement européen il y aurait
forcément ses débats c'est que c'est un
sujet vous voyez bien dans vos auditions
c'est quand même un sujet sensible ça
fait la transition avec la question de
du rapporteur de monsieur le rapporteur
sur ma vision sur les biocarbures de
première génération moi je j'étais donc
à l'ADEME quand ça s'est développé et
encore une fois j'ai pas je voulais pas
laisser teinter de je regrets je pense
que ce qui a été fait à cette époque en
Europe par rapport à ce que faisait les
États-Unis et le Brésil étaient tout à
fait justifiée pour à la fois c'est vrai
il faut le reconnaître c'était pour
apporter à une époque où il y avait de
la jachère dans la politique agricole
commune pour apporter des débouchés à
nos agriculteurs qui se retrouvaient
à ce moment-là dans des situations
économiques difficiles donc il y avait à
la fois de la recherche développement de
l'innovation une diversification pour le
monde agricole mais ça a été assez
rapidement ajusté je pense sur un
intérêt bien compris de l'ensemble de la
chaîne de valeur c'est à dire que je le
redis
l'éthanol a un pouvoir calorifique
inférieur qui est pas très élevé mais un
bon indice d'octane il est mis il est
composé oxygénés dans les essences pour
faire à la place du plomb de l'octane
dans des quantités qui sont raisonnables
alors c'est un coût pour les finances
publiques évidemment puisqu'il y avait
une défisc alisation sur ces
biocarburants ça a eu un coup ce qui
était une source de débat régulièrement
au Sénat pendant toute cette période
mais un intérêt un intérêt technique un
intérêt pour les agriculteurs
le bilan les copylans des biocarbures
première génération n'était pas
exceptionnelle au début mais il s'est
progressivement amélioré pour avoir une
vraie pour pouvoir le qualifier
d'énergie renouvelable
donc je pense que c'est voilà on est
arrivé à un stade mature on ne
n'investit plus en R&D nous sur ces
filières première génération parce que
l'essentiel est fait dans le monde
entier on a travaillé soit le débouché
canne à sucre soit le blé soit la
betterave pour la filière éthanol le
palme le tournesol le colza pour les
filières des stérifications
d'acides gras en adétivation ou en
substitution au gazole donc c'est pour
ça qu'on a un petit peu arrêté est-ce
que ça ça va monter on voit bien qu'on
arrive aux limites qu'on fasse 7 ou 9%,
on va pas monter à 30 ou 40% pour le
véhicule individuel la voie privilégiée
c'est quand même l'électrique
après il y a la question de l'origine de
l'électricité évidemment donc s'il
fallait aller plus loin ou se poser la
question demain de des segments aux
risques d'avoir besoin de biocarburant
de carburant renouvelable liquide ou la
voie électrique ne fonctionne pas il
peut y avoir les poids lourds et il peut
y avoir évidemment le transport aérien
donc je pense mais je peux me tromper
parce que les filières actuelles sont
bien installées et elles ont leur
utilité technique économiques peut-être
qu'elles vont tenir comme ça pendant 10
ou 20 ans mais si on avait des
déplacements à faire ça pourrait être
vers le les carburants pour le transport
aérien qui peuvent avoir des origines
qui sont proches de celles des
carburants de première génération mais
qui peuvent aussi venir directement des
carburants de deuxième génération au
troisième génération ça me fait une
transition pour passer la parole à
Monique excellence sur ta vision à la
fois de la maturité seconde génération
et puis qu'est-ce qu'on a dans les
tiroirs est-ce qu'on peut imaginer avec
nos collègues du CEA que des nouvelles
sources que ce soit des micro-algues ou
autres pourraient nous permettre d'avoir
directement des carburants synthétiques
comme peut-être total ou d'autres vous
en ont parlé
oui j'avais juste une marque sur les
premières génération
il faut le concevoir son changement
d'allocation des terres donc
effectivement passer de 7 à 9 c'est
presque il suffit d'en bouillir de
rendement et on doit pouvoir passer de
cette année et d'ailleurs on travaille
sur ces questions d'amélioration des
rendements en colza en les mélangeant
avec des légumineuses par exemple et ça
te permet d'augmenter les rendements
sans changement d'allocation des terres
donc voilà mais par contre ça ne on peut
pas imaginer que les
carburants aériens sera fait à partir de
biodiesel
issus du colza alors là c'est
superficie énorme qu'il faut avoir donc
ça c'est pas c'est pas la
excuse-moi Monique parce que je voulais
le dire tout à l'heure je l'ai pas dit
il y a un scénario qui prévoit que les
besoins pour le transport aérien
français en carburant renouvelable en
2050 soit de 72 téraw
85% tu m'as dit 85 % des carburants
aériens devraient selon une directive
européenne en 2050 être d'origine
renouvelable et donc si on projette je
ne sais pas sur quelle source on
essaiera de la trouver pour vous la
communiquer les besoins du transport
aérien français projeté en 2050
ça représenterait 72 térawattheure par
an
issus de la biomasse et comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure qu'on avait des
scénarios de biomasse agricole
disponibles entre 130 et 150
terwatt-heure
si on veut atteindre par la biomasse
agricole il pourrait y avoir peut-être
une origine forestière de ces
bucarburants je sais pas c'est tellement
difficile de le dire aujourd'hui mais on
voit que c'est quand même important donc
il va y avoir un vrai sujet politique
dans les prochaines on va dire dans les
10 à 15 prochaines années est-ce que si
je peux utiliser la métaphore aérienne
est-ce que la filière biocarburant
aérien va décoller ou pas et si oui sur
quelle voie technologique est-ce que
c'est sur une source de biomasse
agricole de biomasse forestière ou
carrément une approche complètement
nouvelle avec des micro-algues ou d'une
fermentation qui viendrait de
d'autres substrats mais ça représente un
ou des carburants de synthèse comme le
projet de certains si c'était pas le cas
ça représenterait une partie importante
de la biomasse agricole et si elle est
là elle sera pas ailleurs
pardon
oui juste pour pour compléter autour des
carburants
aériens en fait ce qu'il faut imaginer
c'est qu'on va peut-être amorcer par
l'utilisation la biomasse et on va avoir
donc c'est le développement de toutes
les technologies autour des autour de
l'utilisation de la biomasse pour faire
des du kérosène en fait les
d'origine biologique et ensuite ce qu'il
prévoit c'est de passer sur des
carburants de synthèse hydrogène plus
CO2 sans utilisation de la biomasse mais
ce sont pas des technologies qui sont
matures à l'heure actuelle et donc du
coup il y a cette agilité en permanence
qu'il faut réussir à avoir entre on
démarre avec la biomasse on arrête la
biomasse parce que c'est repris ensuite
par une technologie mature qui purement
carburant synthétique il faut arriver à
avoir cette cette agilité là
pour revenir sur cette future rôle à la
question
alors après c'est un choix en France on
a je pense que nous n'avons pas
actuellement de Bior raffinerie de
deuxième génération qui produit du
carburant il commence si un avoir en
Europe de l'est d'ailleurs ils ont
acheté la licence AXA je sais plus si
c'est la Croatie enfin vous donnera les
les données exactes mais c'est un choix
pour le moment qui ne n'aboutit pas au
niveau français
mais qui commence à intéresser les les
pays de l'Est alors ils ont beaucoup ils
ont bu beaucoup de biomasse et donc eux
ils sont particulièrement intéressés par
l'utilisation de cette biomasse
alors j'ai dit qu'elle est mature elle
mature parce qu'effectivement on produit
l'éthanol on l'a démontré alors
évidemment les rendements sont toujours
améliorables et ce que je vous disais
c'est que le verrou il est en amont sur
la transformation la prétraitement de la
biomasse donc en imaginant des solutions
thermomécaniques enzymatiques pour
arriver à récupérer ces sucres qui vont
nourrir derrière les les bactéries qui
vont faire l'éthanol je sais pas si vous
avez des peut-être à compléter sur
peut-être Nicolas
quelques mots sur l'hydrogène donc en
fait on mène des recherches sur la
production d'hydrogène alors c'est
quelque chose qui est pas très connu
quand on parle de filerie hydrogène mais
sur la production d'hydrogène à partir
de biomasse à partir de déchets par
fermentation c'est là qu'en fait il faut
savoir que l'hydrogène quand on fait de
la méthanisation
l'hydrogène c'est un intermédiaire
réactionnel de la de la longue chaîne de
la réaction de méthanisation et on est
capable dans certaines conditions de
stopper la réaction de fermentation au
niveau de l'hydrogène et donc de
produire de l'hydrogène par fermentation
à partir de biomasse à partir de déchets
partir essentiellement de sucre alors on
est vraiment dans un contexte de Bioré
c'est à dire que cette production
d'hydrogène elle s'accompagne de la
production de co-produits de
fermentation qui va falloir également
valoriser qu'on peut valoriser
différentes façons notamment par
méthanisation mais également par un
procédé qui est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus innovant et
avec un degré de maturation plus faible
qui s'appelle l'électrolyse microbienne
donc l'électrolyse microbien c'est un
procédé d'électrolyse comme celui que
vous connaissez mais la différence est
qu'une partie de la réaction va être
assurée par des micro-organismes et que
la concent la consommation énergétique
en électricité et du coup beaucoup plus
faible que dans un électrolyseur
classique donc là on est sur des encore
une fois sur des maturités
technologiques assez faibles et une
autre possibilité donc là on a un projet
actuellement Nicolas c'est à quelle
échelle ce qu'on fait là sur ce cet
électrolyse microbienne alors là sur la
sur le la fermentation électrolyse
microbienne on est sur du couplage là on
est en train de construire un pilote
pour la fermentation un pilote mobile de
de mémoire c'est quelques centaines de
litres avec un méthaniseur de 3 mètres
cubes d'accord donc on est on est sur du
TRL je dirais à peu près 6 et la matière
première qui va être mise en
fermentation alors là on est sur des bio
déchets d'accord donc des déchets issus
des déchets alimentaires
mais on peut utiliser de ressources et
on produit donc du produit de
l'hydrogène on produit de l'hydrogène
dans l'étape de fermentation et puis
ensuite en fonction du procédé avec
lequel on va coupler si on fait de
l'électrolyse microbienne on va de
nouveau produire également de
l'hydrogène dans la deuxième étape si on
coupe avec de la méthanisation on va
produire du méthane et puis il y a une
troisième option sur laquelle on
travaille en ce moment donc là dans le
cadre d'un projet avec
coordonnées par engie
les procédés métalliques financés par le
Pia via ladem où là on va produire de
l'hydrogène par fermentation à partir de
déchets et ensuite on injecte cette
hydrogène dans un méthaniseur de façon à
enrichir le biogaz en méthane puisque
dans un méthaniseur le biogaz qui est
produit contient du méthane mais il
contient également du CO2 résiduel donc
là l'idée c'est d'aller convertir ce COD
en méthane en injectant de l'hydrogène
qui produit par fermentation
pendant quelques exemples de ce qu'on
fait et en complément aussi sur les sur
les jets fuel on est également en
partenaire d'un projet européen
qui a pour objectif alors là encore on
est sur des niveaux technologiques très
bas l'objectif de ce projet européen
c'est d'arriver alors je sais pas si les
niveaux de TRL vous parlent les TRL
c'est le niveau développement
technologique sur une échelle de 20 à 9
là l'objectif de ce projet européen
c'est d'arriver un trl4 donc vous voyez
qu'on est on est loin de l'application
la recherche fondamentale le 9 c'est le
développement industriel et le 4 c'est à
mi-chemin un petit peu moins donc c'est
encore de la recherche on est à
l'échelle labo mais déjà dans des
procédés un petit peu un petit peu
réalistes et là l'idée c'est d'utiliser
des déchets
pour produire des jets fuel en combinant
alors nous on intervient en amont on est
sur de la fermentation on va produire
des molécules
relativement simple l'idée c'est de
simplifier la complexité des déchets en
les fermentant et en produisant des
molécules plateformes qui vont pouvoir
être utilisés derrière pour des
chimistes
ils vont eux fabriquer
faire de l'élongation de chaîne et
fabriquer les les molécules
intéressantes pour ces pour cette fioul
merci Monsieur Bernay
complément pas de complément oui alors
moi je voudrais peut-être juste
intervenir sur la partie prêtre
traitement ligne cellulose et on en est
finalement dans la recherche bon les
procédés en fait existent donc ça ça
peut préalé et on voit bien que les
efforts à faire aujourd'hui c'est de
gérer la biodiversité et la diversité
plutôt des biomasses qui rentrent dans
les procédés de transformation et on
peut aller du déchet urbain jusque à des
résidus en passant par des coproduits de
l'industrie forestière transformation
des du bois etc et ça c'est un question
de recherche qui est super importante et
la difficulté qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
de récupérer les données d'avoir des
capables de les interpréter de les de
les utiliser ensuite pour décider
comment et vers où cette biomasse doit
aller pour arriver des rendements qui
sont intéressants donc en tant que
scientifique j'ai optimiste mais avec un
pas de temps qui est relativement long
je comprends que il y a de la
immédiateté pardon qui est importante
mais on ne peut pas avoir de la rupture
sans
progresser sur cette thématique là et le
côté ni une cellulose est une biomasse
qui est très complexe à déconstruire et
les micro-organismes ne font pas
forcément tout ce qu'on veut faire d'où
la nécessité de commencer avec des
démonstrations de concept à tiers L4 et
ensuite progressivement les beaucoup
plus haut je voudrais juste dire aussi
que il y a quand même des gros projets
qui dans les peps qui ont été lancés sur
lesquels il y a des activités de
recherche donc importantes sur les
l'impact finalement
la mobilisation des biomasse sur le
cycle du carbone de stockage l'émission
etc donc ça c'est aussi des choses qui
sont en cours mais c'est un pas de temps
de 5 ans il y a des projets sur la vie
économie urbaine qui est aussi donc de
récupérer tout ce qui est possible voilà
avec des technologies donc qui sont
développées LBU à Narbonne et dans
d'autres laboratoires pour provenir de
l'énergie alors petit échelle adapté à
un contexte on parlait territoire mais
la ville c'est un territoire les
campagnes c'est un autre contexte bon
moi je viens toujours pas Lardenne il y
a des biographies mais il y a pas que ça
non plus c'est à dire tout un ensemble
agricole industriels qui aussi a
développé donc voilà il y a plein de
pistes mais les priorités qui sont
données sont claires vieux économie
circularité sobriétaire oui sobriété je
voulais dire ce qui est important on
peut pas produire plus sans que
conjointement on est quelque chose de
sort et juste pour terminer son
mobiliser les discussion je te demande
dans le milieu urbain si vous avez des
bâtiments qui sont des passages
thermiques a forcément vous allez
consommer beaucoup d'énergie pour pas
grand chose on parle de précarité
énergétique mais c'est réel remet des
matériaux qui sont issus du biomasse qui
viennent du biorinerie de biais économie
qui peuvent être circularisés pour
diminuer la quantité d'énergie utilisée
pour chauffer et maintenir une
température à descente ça ça fait partie
de la démarche bon c'est le bâtiment
c'est pas les carburants mais on peut
appliquer exactement la même chose en
raisonnement sur tout ce qui bouge donc
faut alléger il faut savoir pourquoi on
utilise un transport la marchandise les
biens etc et ça c'est aussi des choses
qui peuvent être se traiter au niveau de
l'Institut mais sur du long terme
j'insiste sur le mot long terme voilà
[Musique]
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
pour vos éclairages vraiment parce que
ça nous permet quand même de mieux voir
la biomasse mobilisable surtout
et peut-être que mon questionnement va
vous surprendre voilà
je considère que nous avons assisté
et nous assistons parfois encore
à une certaine tendance à considérer
l'agriculture comme un sou- produit de
l'environnement
je dis pas que c'est votre cas bien
entendu mais dans la société dans le
monde institutionnel lorsque vous
interrogez les personnes elles ont
tendance à vous perdre de vue
la raison d'être première de
l'agriculture qui à mon sens reste de
nourrir
le vivant
donc c'est une réalité et
ma crainte se fonde sur le fait que
l'opinion publique
soit plus sensible
au développement des biocarburants
ou de ces productions un peu
alternatives
qu'à la pérennisation des activités
nourricières de l'agriculture je je
crains cela je vis cela
ce qui peut conduire assez vite à
considérer à donner une préférence au
fond au développement des biomasse dont
on parlait qu'aux développement des
productions agricoles utiles
permettez-moi de prendre juste un
exemple dans mon petit département des
Côtes-d'Armor je viens donc de Bretagne
et en un an
nous avons assisté à la chute d'à peu
près 10 millions de litres de lait de
production
et dans le même temps
je constate un développement de la
végétalisation des termes
qui n'est pas tout à fait la vocation
des terres en question
ce qui a pour effet de générer aussi une
forme de déséquilibre pas seulement
écologique mais aussi agroécologie vous
voyez ce que je donne comme illustration
tentez si bien que je m'interroge
toujours sur la question de la
valorisation économique des productions
alimentaires c'est un vrai un vrai
questionnement qui je pense que beaucoup
nous sommes nombreux à nous interroger
sur cet aspect là des choses parce que
ça me paraît être
une des garanties
pour éviter le risque de dérive dont je
parlais au départ de mon propos je ne
sais pas si vous avez pardonnez-moi si
vos questionnement a été un petit peu
atypique mais
votre éclairage conforte mon
questionnement si je puis dire en tout
cas merci de l'avoir fait
monsieur le sénateur je pense que pour
ce que je vois du de notre pays je pense
qu'on a évité pour le moment trop cette
dérive on a si on regarde le
développement de la méthanisation en
Allemagne dans les années 2000 2010 et
ça a fait ensuite beaucoup de débats
plutôt critiques sur le développement du
biogaz et de la méthanisation en France
il y a des modèles qui se sont
développés il y avait un tel besoin pour
l'Allemagne qu'on peut respecter qui
voulait sortir du nucléaire de
développer des filières d'énergie
renouvelables qu'ils avaient mis des
prix de rachat du biogaz produisant de
l'électricité de l'électricité Sud
biogaz très très élevé et donc des
exploitations
détournaient on va dire des productions
de maïs normalement fait pour
l'alimentation humaine et animale pour
nourrir entre guillemets les
méthaniseurs tellement c'était rentable
le débouché énergie et le coproduit de
l'énergie pour ces grandes exploitations
dans les l'Ender de l'Est de l'Allemagne
devenait l'alimentation
on a pu connaître au Pays-Bas des serres
de maraîchage qui avait une coproduction
de cogénération avec la gestion de de la
chaleur interne à la serre et qui
pouvait prioriser le la production
d'électricité par que génération par
rapport au débouchés alimentaires on
n'est pas dans ce contexte là il me
semble en France
ça parfois énervé les opérateurs mais
parce qu'on dit après des fois on fait
de la surréglementation question de du
collègue Pierre Cuypers tout à l'heure
mais dans le développement de la
méthanisation il y a des bornes qui ont
été mises qui prévoit que on ne peut pas
alimenter si on veut bénéficier des
tarifs de rachat un méthaniseur de plus
de x% j'ai pas le chiffre en tête mais
je dirais peut-être 10% ou 15%
de culture à vocation alimentaire donc
on oriente dans l'alimentation des
méthaniseurs qui pourraient aspirer des
cultures alimentaires de fait on le
réserve plutôt qu'aux produits au
sous-produit que ce soit des déjections
animales ou des ou des écarts de tri par
exemple de légumes ou pommes de terre
donc j'ai l'impression que ce risque est
limité après est-ce que vous décrivez
par contre et un élément réel qui fait
que au moment où il y a une il y a eu
une envolée sur les prix des grandes
cultures liées à la guerre en
Ukraine le développement de l'in qu'on
connaît bien en France et en même temps
une stagnation même s'il y a une petite
amélioration des prix du lait payé aux
producteurs il y a surcroît de travail
de pénibilité qu'on connaît et donc des
agriculteurs ont fait leur compte et on
considéré soit parce qu'ils allaient
bientôt partir en retraite soit parce
qu'ils étaient en cours d'activité que
ça valait plus le coup de garder leur
cheptel laitiers ils ont décapitalisé
pour faire de la production agricole
mais je suis pas sûr que ça soit lié au
débouché énergétique je pense que ça a
été plutôt un effet et on sait que c'est
pas réglé encore dans notre pays de
doutes sur l'avenir des systèmes
d'élevage versus une montée en puissance
des des filières végétales avec la
guerre en Ukraine
je vais je vais regrouper les demandes
d'intervention pour
Nadia ce logo oui merci beaucoup je vous
posais une question qui peut être un
petit peu marginale mais je m'intéresse
je m'interroge souvent sur les plantes
envahissantes ou invasives qui sont
finalement une ressource agricole qui
est juste considéré je sais plus qui a
dit une mauvaise herbe c'est juste une
herbe dont on n'a pas encore trouvé à
quoi elle sert et si voilà il y a-t-il
des recherches parce qu'on a quand même
une ressource végétale qui est
totalement inexploitée alors au niveau
aérien on est envahi de Renaud et du
Japon la justice dans les cours d'eau et
est-ce que on pourrait valoriser dans
une esprit d'économie circulaire et puis
ce que vous étiez permis d'élargir un
petit peu le débat sur les passoires
énergétiques moi quand j'étais mère
j'étais toujours agacée de payer de
l'énergie dans la salle où il y avait
les ordinateurs pour les refroidir et
dans la pièce d'à côté on payait de
l'énergie dans la salle où on
travaillait pour réchauffer
donc je me dis toujours que on est on
n'est pas encore très bon en économie
circulaire parce que il y a là pour le
coup d'une énergie fatale j'ai
complètement dérapé mais je voulais
quand même utiliser le débat pour pour
faire cette remarque
oui merci monsieur le Président
juste deux questions
est-ce que l'inrae suit la production de
microalgues
si oui qu'en pensez-vous et sinon
pourquoi l'inrain s'intéresse pas à la
micro-ondes et la deuxième question les
méthaniseurs on a encore compris que la
que donc il y a eu des gros
investissements en termes de
méthanisation et en et en production
pour la première génération on continue
d'investir et est-ce qu'ils seront
adaptables pour la deuxième génération
de carburant
je veux bien entendre la fin de la
question c'est quand même temps je me
renseignais sur microalgue et du coup
j'ai raté la fin de votre question
excusez-moi
en ce qui concerne les méthaniseurs on
continue le développement de méthanisa
aujourd'hui pour la production de
carburantes première génération est-ce
qu'ils seront adaptables pour la
production de carburantes de deuxième
génération
est-ce que est-ce qu'ils pourront servir
pour la génération pour la deuxième
génération de carburant ou on aura des
process complètement différents qui
seront développés
Béatrice
seule question que je voulais poser mais
peut-être que j'ai mal compris quand
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure que il
fallait récupérer les données les
difficultés de récupérer les données
est-ce que c'est les données notamment
parce que vous avez parlé beaucoup de
productions d'hydrogène ou production de
méthane grâce aux déchets donc est-ce
que c'est les données pour justement
faire cette économie de circulaire de
récolte des dossiers et de la quantité
de déchets qu'on pouvait utiliser ce que
c'est ça ou c'est autre chose
la suite de l'intervention de Vincent
mon collègue Vincent
on a visité vendredi le CEA de Cadarache
ou manifestement ils sont sur les mêmes
créneaux que quel est votre coin
vous travaillez sur les mêmes choses
et donc la question c'est
ce qui serait pas
utile que de deux centres de recherche
comme les vôtres d'autant plus qui sont
dans le secteur public
puisse finir leur force pour peut-être
progresser plus rapidement et la
deuxième chose et c'est une question
qu'on on peut répéter chaque fois c'est
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
on a une ligne directrice sur l'une des
solutions possibles pour l'avenir
entre biomasse première génération
deuxième troisième hydrogène
[Musique]
tout électrique etc puisque on
s'aperçoit que il y a une palette de
possible et aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
d'orientation définitive c'est à dire
qu'on laisse chercher les uns et les
autres de chaque côté que ce soit
d'ailleurs les établissements de
recherche que les les utilisateurs ou
éventuellement des sociétés privées par
ailleurs type total ou autre
est-ce que vous pensez qu'un jour on
arrivera une solution qui soit plus
universelle voilà
j'ai peut-être commencé par la question
sur le stratégie de recherche et le CEA
et puis j'ai pas noté toutes les
questions de mes collègues l'ont fait
donc on va y répondre au maximum ensuite
on est bien plutôt bien coordonné je
pense avec le CEVA mais aussi avec le
CNRS et les autres acteurs de la
recherche pour donner un exemple sur les
micro-algues c'est le CEA et c'est pas
nous donc c'est la réponse à votre
collègue et ça fait déjà un paquet
d'années puisque quand j'étais j'avais
créé moi un groupement de recherche
nationale sur l'agriculture pour la
chimie et l'énergie dans les années 95
2000 et il y avait tous les opérateurs
de recherche dedans et effectivement le
CEVA était déjà chargé de travailler sur
la voie microalgue et on avait le
sentiment à l'époque je crois que ce que
me disait Luke fiodo en aparté c'est
toujours le cas c'est que ça paraît très
séduisant comme technologie mais on
arrive à des teneurs des densités en
matière sèches qui sont quand même
faibles et donc
c'est le côté un peu magique du
caractère renouvelable et d'avoir ces
micro-algues on imagine du changement
d'échelle mais quand on se projette dans
une logistique pour
filtrer la matière produite en avoir des
quantités suffisantes et puis après la
sécher la déshydrater l'utiliser etc
c'est une autre paire de manche mais bon
le CEVA a dit vous l'avez vu quand même
des infrastructures technologiques
impressionnantes et c'est bien qu'il
continue de travailler là-dessus à moyen
terme il travaille aussi sur d'autres
sujets en énergie qui sont très
importantes que ce soit sur la voie
hydrogène
notamment nous on est plutôt comme on
l'a dit et là je pense pas qu'on est en
recouvrement avec eux sur la voie des
carburants issus de la biomasse
carburant liquide et puis la
méthanisation le biogaz l'hydrogène donc
plutôt complémentaire et on retrouve au
sein de l'Institut Carnot 3b4 donc il
faut peut-être dire ce que signifie
l'acronyme Luc c'est institut Carnot que
pilote inrae c'est un institut dont
justement le but est de coordonner
l'ensemble des organismes recherche qui
travaillent sur la biomasse dans leur
relation avec les entreprises donc si
une entreprise petite ou grande un sujet
elle est plutôt que de taper à la porte
de tous les organismes elle peut
s'adresser à l'Institut Carnot à trois
becquarts et avoir une présentation de
l'ensemble de dispositifs français de
recherche peut-être lu quelques éléments
sur trois bécarts et des organismes qui
sont dedans très brièvement sur le
Carnot 3 Becquart qui est qui
effectivement piloté par l'inrae
déjà l'acronyme car nous trois d'écart
donc c'est carbone renouvelables pour
les biomolécules donc les molécules
biosourcées les biomatériaux matériaux
biosourcés et les bioénergies
donc les 3B c'est ça la démarche elle
est très intégrative au niveau bio
économique et y compris la biographie
c'est-à-dire que la sortie est bien
bioénergie mais pas exclusivement dans
les bioénergies il y a effectivement les
biocarburants ou les agro-carburants
comme on voudrait les dénommer et au
sein de ce Carnot alors qui est un des
Carnot parmi les 39 du réseau Carnot on
est effectivement structuré en interne
sous la forme de réseau on a le
on a la responsabilité d'un de ces
réseaux qui s'appelle produits
biosourcés pour la bio-économie P2 mais
on est alors qui couvre nos deux champs
thématiques qui sont bio
molécules et biomatériaux en revanche on
est également impliqué dans une autre
dans une autre alliance qui est
l'alliance effic
qui signifie énergie à faible impact
carbone et dans lequel je veux souligner
le fait que on est le seul Carnot qui
traite des alternatives basées sur
l'utilisation de la biomasse les autres
sont des voies alternatives
technologiques
je voulais justementionner ce point là
et ça fait ça fait partie j'avais vu
votre rapport qui a été publié en
2020 je crois sur le rapport numéro 136
sur lequel vous faisiez l'inventaire de
l'ensemble des financesment de la
recherche publique à travers les
différents projets à NR et
il me semble qu'il y avait l'ADEME et
VPI France qui était repris mais il y a
également ce levier des carnots qui doit
être souligné voilà et pour compléter la
réponse qui était apportée effectivement
sur les micro-algues on collabore
puisque le CEA est impliqué dans les
Carnot 3 BK à travers sa structure lpcv
alors qui est une approche plus
fondamentale que l'entité que vous avez
visité à Cadarache on est sur de la
photo bio-réaction culture photo
bioréacteur il y a cette entité là à
échelle je dirais semi-industriel et
vous avez également les installations du
GEPA et algosolis côté du côté de
Saint-Nazaire
donc on échange là-dessus on est
toujours sur l'utilisation de
biocataliseur avec leurs avantages et
leurs inconvénients c'est inhérent la
biodiversité
après sur la question que vous posez sur
y a-t-il pourquoi il y a pas une
stratégie nationale décidée par les
pouvoirs publics et du coup y compris en
matière de recherche sur les voies de
développement des bioénergie
c'est une très bonne question je crois
qu'il y a on est à la fois sur des
secteurs réglementés l'énergie et soit
des secteurs où il y a une forme de
concurrence avec dans le domaine du gaz
on le sait ou même dans le domaine de
l'énergie tout court l'ouverture du
marché européen à la concurrence ça a
fait suffisamment débattre et du coup il
y a voilà il y a une part de une part
des des sujets qui sont liés à la
tarification soit des carburants via les
discussions fiscales que vous connaissez
bien les prix de rachat de l'électricité
quand on est sur l'électricité
renouvelable la PPE qui donne quand même
un cadre ça a été je pense assez
structurant
se rajoutent là en ce moment à la
discussion sur le projet de Loire
énergie climat et la SNBC donc je pense
que ce qu'on n'a pas connu encore on va
peut-être la voir demain dans le cadre
du débat France nation verte la
planification écologique avec l'exercice
j'ai pas j'ai pas d'infos privilégié
mais quand on regarde le fait qu'il va y
avoir une stratégie nationale bas
carbone qui va donner des termes de
référence pour tous les secteurs les
transports le bâtiment l'agriculture
l'industrie en termes d'évolution de
production de carbone à l'horizon de
2050 d'un côté la loi de programmation
de l'énergie de l'autre qui fixe aussi
des conditions et des tarifs de rachat
je pense que pour les opérateurs ça va
permettre d'avoir une vision un peu plus
claire de comment les choses peuvent se
développer il y a
sur les pour le moment on voit qu'il y a
des biocarbures de première génération
qu'on trouvait à leur place dans un
marché qui est celui d'aujourd'hui des
transports routiers des carburants de la
fiscalité des carburants on a une vision
à 10 ans ça va pas changer beaucoup
probablement après le électrique va
monter en puissance le thermique va
progressivement sortir et c'est assez
horizons là que c'est moins clair
qu'est-ce qui va être la part il y aura
probablement du thermique encore et les
véhicules par qui puissent continuer de
rouler seront pas tous arrêtés du jour
au lendemain et donc quels seront les
carburants dans cette période année 2030
2040 qui feront tourner les véhicules
thermiques individuels routiers c'est
une question moi j'ai pas forcément la
réponse pour pour le parc roulant après
il y aura les de plus en plus
d'électrique vraisemblablement et de
l'hybride nous ce qu'on aura accumulé
comme savoir et savoir-faire sera
toujours disponible sur matière première
qui existeront mais il faudra veiller
aux équilibres en priorisant
l'alimentation comme on l'a dit et
secondairement l'énergie et puis il y a
la question qui est peut-être la mieux
repérer par les pouvoirs publics et les
acteurs c'est les jets fuels parce que
ils ont le sentiment que là les
alternatives électriques sont pas
apportées de sont pas apportées de fusil
donc je vois un petit peu je pense que
les cartes vont se clarifier un peu mais
on pourrait très utilement avoir une
discussion multi-acteur de la recherche
pouvoir public opérateur pour réfléchir
à ces scénarios là encore une fois une
fois qu'on aura la SNBC avec la PPE je
pense qu'on aura les éléments pour le
faire
Monique juste pour ajouter un point ce
qui est difficile à apprendre en compte
c'est l'évolution des technologies et
sur 2050 en fait ce qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut arriver à voir c'est qu'il y a
effectivement certains noms de solutions
qui sont matures à partir de la biomasse
mais on va buter à un moment donné
évidemment sur cette disponibilité de la
biomasse mais en même temps on le voit
bien l'hydrogène commence à sortir la
capture de CO2 il commence à avoir des
démonstrateurs si vous avez écouté
l'interroger l'IFPEN ils sont à fond
dans ces dans ces logiques là mais c'est
pas prêt encore industrialiser donc
voilà il y a pas une solution il va y
avoir un ensemble de solutions qui vont
petit à petit se tuer et se développer
alors après dès qu'on parle que ça soit
du du jet fuel que ça soit
l'électricité pour les voitures légères
mais après tout ce qui est aussi
véhicule 31 transport de marchandises
après derrière c'est l'énergie
donc là ça va être la demande en énergie
on aura plus la question biomasse mais
on aura la question énergétique il va
falloir énormément d'énergie électrique
comment on fait c'est sur
la seconde génération c'est bien ce que
ce que dit Monique c'est des étapes clés
qui sont sur le pré-traitement et
l'association d'opérations unitaires que
l'on semble maîtriser quand elles sont
prises individuellement or on va souvent
les associer ça peut être du couplage
entre de la chimie verte et des
biotechnologies qui induit une
complexité et ça on est obligé de
l'aborder au niveau de la recherche dans
un premier temps donc on fait face à une
on va dire une grande diversification et
diversité des intrants en termes de
matrice
leur prêt traitement thermique
mécaniques chimiques et où bio
catalytique au sens enzymatique c'est
souvent des enzymes qui sont utilisées à
ce niveau là pour l'obtention de la
brique élémentaire qui est un sucre
fermentissime la plupart du temps
nécessis très difficile avec les C5 et
ensuite de réutiliser cette brique
élémentaire comme substrat par un
d'autres bio catalyseur qui va être un
bio catalyseur microbien pour produire
des molécules d'intérêt qui peuvent être
de l'éthanol dans certains cas mais qui
peuvent être des saintes c'est-à-dire
des molécules plateformes et on fait le
lien avec la biographie et l'utilisation
autre que le carburant ou le
biocarburant au sens strictus
et ça je pense que c'est très important
parce que ça nous a amené à développer
en interne je pense que Bernard pourra
compléter des techniques d'analyse et de
caractérisation des intrants mais aussi
de la manière dont on les obtient et
aussi comment on va les transformer et
quels sont les défis les défis
scientifiques que l'on veut relever
derrière
et donc typiquement pour la question de
Madame la siennettrice on l'a pas fait à
ma connaissance mais on pourrait le
faire si vous avez un gisement connu de
mauvaises herbes ou de plantes invasives
qui est repéré spatialement et dont on
peut caractériser le contenu la
composition on peut voir après quels
sont les voix de traitement de
pré-traitement possible soit pour faire
de la fermentation ou de la
méthanisation mais il faudra avoir des
gisements quand même assez important
pour que on puisse amortir à la fois les
coûts de R&D et puis ensuite les coûts
transformation
c'est toujours une question de récolte
on peut on peut tout imaginer on avait
aussi pensé à toutes les toutes l'herbe
en bord des routes en bord des voisins
les algues vertes tout ça le problème
c'est qu'il faut il faut récolter et en
fait ce qu'on découvre avec la biomasse
par rapport à au nucléaire ou l'énergie
on était habitué avant c'est que ces
territorialisé et vous ne ferez pas la
même chose quand vous êtes du côté de
dans le sud-est ou quand vous êtes dans
le dans les Côtes-d'Armor et donc du
coup c'est cette notion qui va falloir
adapter la solution et c'est ça qu'on a
du mal à
faire cette question et juste pour que
monsieur avait posé la question là sur
là la méthanisation les méthaniseurs ils
font du bioga ça et c'est pas une
logique de première génération de
deuxième génération ça c'est pour les
carburants
le méthaniseur il prend en général un
mélange de de déchets agricoles des
fluents d'élevage dessives et problèmes
des déchets ménagers ils fabriquent du
méthane
c'est peut-être la référence à l'État
nation non la première génération c'est
l'utilisation des du des grains de blé
les grains de maïs la betterave donc en
concurrence directe avec l'alimentation
des carburants liquides
l'éthanol
d'accord c'était ça qu'on parlait de
premier et deuxième génération on
l'utilise moins alors on pourrait
l'utiliser aussi pour le biogaz entre
des différentes techniques évoquées par
Nicolas Bernay mais en l'occurrence on a
beaucoup parlé de première génération de
biocarbures en liquide
éthanol issue de betteraves blé Esther
de colza ou de tournesol pour ensuite
parler de biocarburant de seconde
génération la même molécule d'éthanol
mais
issue de sous-produit de débris de
paille de drêches ou bien voilà donc
c'était ça la différence entre première
et deuxième génération première
génération c'est la matière première
agricole alimentaire ce qu'on essaye
d'éviter maintenant pour plutôt
travailler sur des déchets ou produits
pour toujours essayer de produire les
mêmes le même type de molécules qui ont
un intérêt en additivation des
carburants et la troisième génération
c'est même plus par de la matière
première agricole c'est la fermentation
et ou des productions qui viendraient de
micro-algues qui peuvent être
éventuellement soit naturels ou modifier
génétiquement ou de macroalgue pour
produire les mêmes molécules mais cette
troisième génération elle est encore
plus éloignée dans le temps parce que on
a des rendements qui sont encore plus
faibles
est intéressante en théorie mais le
temps qu'on arrive à augmenter les
rendements après avoir des techniques
d'extraction de collecte pour arriver
aux produits c'est quand même très très
éloigné l'avantage des premières
générations c'est que ça marche
aujourd'hui les deuxième génération
comme on le disait tout à l'heure on a
réussi à montrer que c'était possible de
le faire de façon industrielle mais à
des coûts qui sont supérieurs à cause de
ce prétraitement d'une matière première
qui est
très hétérogène à vous imaginer soit des
des tas de paille soit des grains de blé
c'est par le même coup pour accéder au
sucre
au glucose de partir d'un grain de blé
qu'on va faire fermenter assez
facilement ou de partir de d'un tas de
paille qui va falloir fractionner casser
la ligne ou la ligne cellulose pour que
ensuite la fermentation soit possible
il y a une bonne il y a une bonne image
c'est le si vous êtes en forêt et c'est
le vieux bois il y a une question de
temps mais là on a pas les champignons
et d'ailleurs on utilise les champignons
pour essayer de trouver des nouvelles
molécules qui permettent de dégrader la
ligne cellulose mais là on n'a pas le
temps il faut le faire rapidement et
c'est ça toute la tous l'enjeu quoi
Lucien tu veux
juste une réflexion par rapport à la
biomasse de plutôt le biocarburant de
première génération on a eu le débat ici
avec les représentants du monde agricole
sur la question de est-ce qu'on utilise
les terres pour des productions
vivrières ou pour pour effectivement
faire du carburant et donc ça d'ailleurs
c'est un débat qui continue à traverser
le monde agricole de façon importante
je voulais répondre aussi sur les
données en fait tout ce qui est idéal
montre bien la nécessité de connaître
finalement ce qu'on manipule et alors
diversité des ressources oui donc il
faut savoir ce que c'est la nature en
fait c'est quelques constituants qui
sont assemblés d'une manière très
différente à chaque fois selon
l'organisme qu'on considère la matière
qu'on considère donc si on connaît cette
matière là on peut probablement beaucoup
mieux imaginer comment on va la
déconstruire c'est là que je voulais
parler des données et ça rejoint la
question de bah ok pourquoi est-ce que
là c'est positif de mettre tel type de
culture faire tel transformation et on
peut mesurer on peut vraiment quantifier
l'intérêt d'avoir ça pour tout le monde
d'ailleurs que ça soit l'agriculteur le
consommateur la terre tout le reste et
pourquoi dans d'autres endroits ça
marche pas tout n'est pas transposable
et donc il faut bien avoir les données
pour être capable de modéliser et de
comprendre ce qui se passe et ça c'est
un enjeu qui est conseiller parce que
encore une fois on revient sur le temps
alors il y a déjà du capital parce qu'on
a beaucoup de données mais on mettrait
ça en forme le le traité leur utilisé et
en fait c'est quand même difficulté
qu'on a eu lorsqu'on a réfléchi sur les
réponses à apporter c'est que il y a
énormément de de connaissances
dispersées il faut être capable de la
rassembler pour l'utiliser correctement
et ça aussi c'est un travail de
scientifique et qui est je pense très
important à mettre en oeuvre pour tout
le monde en fait voilà
monsieur le rapporteur merci Monsieur
président trois questions si rapide que
possible la première c'est sur la
deuxième génération j'y reviens
qu'est-ce qui manque en France pour que
ça ça puisse fonctionner alors on a
compris que du point de vue
technologique ça marche
certains nous disent alors je mets
notamment je vais juste wifi là mais
certains nous disent on veut des mandats
d'incorporation clair on va avoir de la
visibilité bon
est-ce que ça suffira et puis plus
globalement quelles sont les sujets sur
lesquels vous auriez envie de nous
pousser à faire des propositions puisque
cette mission on va produire un rapport
dans l'idée d'accélérer ou en tout cas
de contribuer à la décarbonation de ces
secteurs là on retransport et industrie
pour faire vite et donc quels seraient
les points d'amélioration que les
pouvoirs publics pourraient mettre en
oeuvre ou sur lesquels il serait bon
qu'on s'interroge nous après on verra ce
qu'on en fait mais ça c'est assez
concret le dernier point encore plus
concret sur la biomasse madame la
effleuré tout à l'heure mais comment on
résout la question de la collecte et
est-ce que c'est
vraiment un verrou difficile à surmonter
ou pas est-ce que vous avez regardé ce
point-là
simplement pour la filière bois comme
comment vous fonctionnez et vous
rapporte avec l'ONF
voilà comment ça se passe dans la
filière bois excellent alors
sur le peut-être commencer par la
filière bois donc on a très bon rapport
avec l'ONF mais pas uniquement avec les
l'ensemble des opérateurs que ce soit le
les propriétés les propriétaires
forestiers CNPF les communes forestières
on a le centre de techniques du bois et
de l'ameublement le FCBA et donc on est
on a associé l'ensemble de ces
partenaires dans un programme
prioritaire de recherche qu'on va
piloter à la demande du Gouvernement sur
l'avenir des forêts françaises face aux
dérèglement climatique évidemment des
très très gros enjeux donc on a une
bonne coordination il faut reconnaître
et peut-être que ça fera un lien aussi
avec eux la question que sur le
rapporteur posait sur des suggestions
c'est vrai qu'on a pas de grands
programmes de recherche
orientés bioénergie en ce moment
on a un grand programme de recherche qui
nous a été demandé qu'on copilote qu'on
va copiloter avec l'IFPEN
sur les plutôt biomellicules orientés
décarbonations
transformations sur les projets process
de transformation de la biomasse et
production de biomolécules et
biomatériaux mais c'est pas l'énergie
qui est ciblée en tant que tel sous ton
contrôle Monique puisque c'est toi qui
le prépare et sur la forêt on en a qui
est sur la forêt en tant que tel et sa
résistance aux dérèglement climatique
mais qui va pas jusqu'à la
transformation des bois et en tous les
cas pas sur la production de d'énergie
ou de molécules donc la question
pourrait se poser de se dire est-ce que
puisque France 20 30 que vous connaissez
quand même
un ensemble de programmes très
intéressant et nous on est déjà pilote
de plusieurs programmes on a un
programme sur l'accélération de la
transition agroécologique et le
numérique on en a sur l'alimentation
saine et durable on en a sur la
prévention des pandémies on va en
piloter un donc sur les biomolécules
mais il y en a pas sur les bioénergie en
tant que tel peut-être parce que les
poux ça revient un peu toujours sur
notre discussion peut-être parce que les
pouvoirs publics et les opérateurs
considèrent que les technologies sont en
bonne partie mature et que là où il y a
de la rupture technologique c'est
l'hydrogène le véhicule hydrogène est là
il y a un PEPR qui est parti et sur les
batteries sur les piliers hydrogène sur
la voie électronique mais pas
probablement doit pas considérer les jet
fuels c'est un sujet qui intéresse
Boeing qui intéresse Airbus et chaque
compagnie regarde j'imagine que Total
évidemment à ses propres programme de
recherche là-dessus mais ça a pas été
identifié comme un sujet pour porter un
programme d'intérêt national voilà
biocarburant du futur pour pour le
transport aérien par exemple c'est voilà
on a ou le transport d'une manière
générale il y en a pas vraiment
aujourd'hui nous on en fait sur nos
propres fonds comme le CEA le Carnot
permet d'avoir des partenariats je
honnêtement on se plains pas mais il y a
pas
on n'a pas formulé à ce jour un grand
programme sur le sur le sujet
la question qu'est-ce qui manque pour
que
y ait un réel décollage de la seconde
génération en France on pensait en être
passé pas loin avec futural probablement
qu'il existe pas aujourd'hui un mandat
d'incorporation obligatoire et où une
incitation dédiée à cette seconde
génération je crois je suis pas non plus
forcément au fait de tout les arcanes de
la réglementation européenne et
nationale mais je pense que il y en a
pas aujourd'hui donc la compétit irrivée
relative de ces filières de seconde
génération est en moins bonne que celle
de première génération n'a pas trouvé
son marché si on voulait la pousser on
pourrait imaginer des mandats
insuffisants ou des mandats on arrive à
les atteindre sans sans ça s'il y avait
un mandat dédié qui disait bah tiens il
faut à l'horizon je dis vraiment
n'importe quoi 2030 ou 2028 il faut
qu'il y ait deux ou trois pour cent dans
les 13 ou 14% de la directive européenne
il y en a trois ou quatre pour cent qui
devront impérativement venir et être
pour tous les distributeurs
issus de cette seconde génération ça
mettrait peut-être les acteurs
économiques en situation de se dire bon
bah on va avoir un enjeu on va avoir un
marché une cible on se prépare à
investir comme c'est à ma connaissance
pas le cas en tous les cas pas de façon
vraiment contraignante pour le moment
ils estiment que le jeu dans vaut pas la
chandelles et que ça serait un risque à
prendre donc il y a il y a peut-être
quelque chose à imaginer si on voulait
vraiment avoir une référence ou des
références en Europe si c'est
dites-le Lucas si vous voyez c'est la
même chose on est remonté sur les
mandats enfin
l'état actuel des discussions
européennes se fait que ça en fonction
remonte mais est-ce que c'est assez pour
que économique
et c'est pas sous votre contrôle du coup
c'est une question du coup que je vous
retourne c'est pas un mandat impératif
pour la seconde génération
si si c'est un mandat impératif qui doit
être obligatoirement atteint ou c'est
quand on va au dessus des 7%. alors bon
le diable est toujours dans les détails
il faut que on regarde c'est ce qui a
été stabilisé il y a notamment trois
semaines je pense de mémoire alors
est-ce qu'on a tous les textes pour être
un minimum prudent mais quand même mais
en gros ce que nous disent les
raffineurs pour des choses clairement
c'est on voudrait des mandats plus
importants et une visibilité plus
importante voilà mais il y a des progrès
on voit bien après il faut regarder les
détails et est-ce que est-ce que ça la
transformation d'une
raffinerie en bio raffinerie on a visité
ensemble La Mède bon c'est quand même
pas si simple que ça
bon voilà on a vu des
personnels très investis il faut saluer
cet effort c'est pas rien mais mais
quand même
il faut que ça tourne tout ça alors
après on nous dit aussi que finalement
autant le faire sur des sites existants
et avec des personnels et que peut-être
que ça coûtera moins cher en faisant
comme ça bon j'entends le raisonnement
je pense que ça il faut le vérifier
aussi oui c'est vrai qu'il y a en tous
les cas le CAPEX de ces investissements
sont très élevés donc il y a peut-être à
regarder Sam pour le coup là on est un
peu à la limite à la limite de nos
compétences bien entendu plusieurs
dizaines de milliards si on voulait
alors j'ai pas tout raisonnement en tête
c'est pas mes notes avec moi mais si on
voulait être en ligne avec les objectifs
pour la vérifier ou par exemple
c'est ça c'est ça notamment sur La Mède
mais là c'est on va aligner les dizaines
de milliards de dizaines de milliards et
donc la question c'est qu'il aimait
soit c'est de l'aide fiscale soit c'est
de c'est le consommateur final
et c'est rendu obligatoire c'est la
question qui a pour le biogaz aussi soit
c'est c'est une obligation fait pour le
distributeur mais ça veut dire que c'est
répercuté sur le consommateur
simplement c'était pour
compléter ce que dit monsieur le
rapporteur c'est qu'on a l'impression
que en fait
mais ça dépasse notre débat là on a un
état de fait qui fait que d'ailleurs on
a toujours du pétrole
et que on a plutôt tendance à avoir
envie de rien changer dans le système
c'est un peu ça le sentiment qu'on a on
a rencontré multitude de personnes
on a l'impression que alors il y a plein
de choses qui sont en plein plein
intéressantes bon mais au bout du bout
on a l'impression que pour l'instant on
garde le système qui tourne qui tourne
quoi bon voilà bon sauf que je crois que
l'histoire va nous rattraper quoi un
moment donné
et que ne sera-t-il pas trop tard
Lucien t'as raison notre espèce animale
cherche toujours son confort depuis télé
sur terre donc c'est un problème cela
dit il me semble qu'il y a des
prévisions au niveau du climat qui font
que il vaudrait mieux arrêter de
produire du coco 2 et donc et le temps
nous est compté si j'ai bien compris et
puis il y a quelque chose qu'on réalise
mal c'est les conséquences sur le
changement climatique en termes
d'événements voilà y compris au bord de
la mer pour des futurs repères etc etc
je vois ce qu'on a du mal à se projeter
parce que ces événements là pour le
moment on les connaît pas voilà je pense
qu'on a je voulais vous remercier de
nous avoir accordé du temps de
l'éclairage et puis vous avoir donné des
chiffres
un moment ça ça permet de mesurer dans
dans son cerveau un peu les
difficultés ou moi qui nous attendent en
tous les cas merci beaucoup de nous
avoir raconté du temps y compris pour
Narbonne
je suis désolé j'avais comme on parlait
de dos carburant aviation Toulouse c'est
pas très loin c'est pas très loin et
donc c'est un laboratoire qui a été créé
sous le contrôle de Nicolas en 1933 à
Narbonne pour traiter des effluents des
cas viticoles et qui est aujourd'hui un
des meilleurs labos au niveau mondial
sur la méthanisation
à Narbonne quand vous allez dans l'Aude
voilà vous êtes les bienvenus oui quand
il y a pas de vent
merci beaucoup merci à tous pour votre
écoute et votre accueil